[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver sur les chaînes parlementaires
pour un nouveau numéro de Parlement
Hebdo l'émission qui revient sur
l'actualité de la semaine au Parlement
avec vos catégories Alexandre et cette
semaine nous accueillons Laurent
marquant Gelly bonjour Merci d'être sur
le plateau de Parlement Hebdo vous êtes
président du groupe horizon à
l'Assemblée nationale le parti d'Édouard
philippe qui vient d'ailleurs de fêter
son premier anniversaire vous êtes
député de corde du Sud Ajaccio et il y a
beaucoup d'actualités pour vous et à la
une cette semaine l'examen du budget à
l'Assemblée nationale qui s'avère très
compliqué pour le gouvernement face à
des oppositions Unies et animées divisée
l'exécutif qui se prépare à dégainer le
49.3 la réforme des retraites et la
première ministre Elisabeth borne qui
mène la concertation avec les différents
groupes parlementaires on verra quels
sont leurs attentes
et puis au Sénat l'examen du projet de
loi Love Me d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur la majorité de droite du
Sénat approuve la hausse des moyens des
forces de l'ordre mais souhaite durcir
les peines de prison pour certains
délits
la discussion du projet de loi de
finance se poursuit donc en séance
publique dans la douleur dès le coup
d'envoi du débat budgétaire le
gouvernement a subi une série de revers
a commencé par l'article liminaire qui a
été rejeté d'entrée de jeu
l'ambiance est électrique les
oppositions semblant s'unir sur
certaines dispositions et le
gouvernement menaçant de couper court au
débat explication avec ce compte rendu
de séance de Stéphanie Despierres
l'ombre du 49.3 plane sur l'hémicycle
mais à l'ouverture des débats le
ministre de l'Économie veut se laisser
du temps il n'y a pas de bataille de
budget il y a un débat sur le budget
dialogue
c'est la seule façon d'améliorer ce
projet de budget 2023 qui par définition
reste perfectible et doit être améliorée
par les parlementaires sauf que ça
commence mal l'article qui pose le
principe de base du budget 5% de déficit
public pour 2023 et rotoqué mercredi
soir la question des supers profits
revient comme un boomerang et par le
modem pourtant allié du gouvernement
avec le soutien de toute la gauche du RN
et de 19 députés Renaissance le modem
parvient à faire voter une taxe
supplémentaire non pas sur les profits
mais sur les supers dividendes on est
vraiment sur une notion de super
dividende plus 20% par rapport à la
moyenne des dividendes ça incite les
entreprises à investir leur bénéfice
dans le développement dans la dans la
transition donc je pense que c'est
quelque chose de vertueux voilà depuis
trois ans la France est redevenue le
pays le plus attractif pour les
investissements ét en Europe tout ça on
le doit à une politique qui est
cohérente et j'allais être simplement
sur l'effet signal de dispositif qui
viendrait brouiller brouiller cette
politique qui a été mise en place depuis
5 ans et qui porte ses fruits sur la
fiscalité des EHPAD les reversant chaîne
calmement mais sûrement l'assemblée des
tricote le texte les députés Renaissance
font pression pour que le gouvernement
déclenche le 49-3 mais Bruno Le Maire
tient bon ce ne sera pas cette semaine
je dis l'opposition aussi s'impatiente
et réclame des garanties c'est la
troisième fois que je demande vous
n'étiez pas là auparavant si tous les
amendements qui auront été adoptés ici
seront repris dans le projet de loi de
finance finale qui sera peut-être
imposée par le 49-3 il serait bien qu'on
ait une réponse pas de réponse des
ministres les débats continuent en
attendant le 49-3
le remarque Angélie le gouvernement
semble très malvené dans ce débat la
majorité a subi une série de revers sur
des dispositions importantes une
question très simple que se passe-t-il
dans la majorité il se passe tout
simplement que le 19 juin dernier les
Français ont élu des députés et de ces
élections il n'est pas sorti de
majoritable absolue et que c'est un fait
inédit il se passe que la chef du
gouvernement dans son discours de
politique générale à la demande du
Président de la République a rappelé
qu'elle souhaitait créer des compromis
des consensus et il se passe que
malheureusement certains ne veulent pas
de céder à consensus de ses compromis et
joue parfois sur certains votes à
l'Assemblée la politique c'est cohérent
pour vous que les LR votent comme les
insoumis d'abord je suis toujours
particulièrement
surpris interpellé interloqué lorsque je
vois les députés LFI se lever en même
temps que les députés RN écrié Oura
parce que un vote est d'aller dans le
sens qui était le leur à savoir celui de
battre le gouvernement quoi qu'il arrive
et quoi qu'il présente ça c'est déjà
quelque chose qui s'est passé à de
nombreuses reprises pendant la session
extraordinaire du mois de juillet et ça
continue et je pense que certes on est
dans l'opposition on veut mettre en
difficulté le gouvernement j'ai été
député de l'opposition entre 2012 et
2017 ici mais c'est de la France dont on
parle des Français et sur les
républicains les députés LR qui votent
les mêmes amendements que les insoumis
le règne comment vous juger leur vote
c'est pas moi qui suis là pour les juger
c'est leurs électeurs je ne pense pas
que celles et ceux qui ont voté pour un
ou une candidate LR au mois de juin
dernier les faits pour qu'il vote avec
la France insoumise ou avec le
rassemblement national ou sinon
peut-être que je me trompe au sein de la
majorité il y a aussi certaines
divisions comment vous expliquer ces
divisions il y a pas des divisions il y
a des affirmations de différence
notamment de la part de du MoDem qui est
dans la même le MoDem a proposé
un amendement qui effectivement mardi
soir à fait parler de lui sur les super
dividendes pour taxer les super
dividendes je sais que le président
Mattei lors des nombreuses réunions que
nous avons eu depuis le début de cette
mandature parler beaucoup de la
différenciation entre super profit et
super dividendes donc il a joint la
parole aux actes en déposant cette
amendement qui a fait l'objet d'une
discussion approfondie avec une
opposition du gouvernement au fait
d'inscrire cet amendement dans le
dispositif de notre projet de loi de
finance l'assemblée est libérée
souverainement et elle a accepté
l'amendement mais vous pensez que cette
disposition dans le texte final qui
sortira de l'assemblée que le
gouvernement a gardé cette disposition
qui taxe les super profits ou pas les
super dividendes pardon je l'ignore je
l'ignore pour le moment tout ce que je
souhaite que ça soit conserver vous
savez c'est très difficile ça va être
très difficile de justifier le fait que
tout ou partie des amendements qui ont
été votés ne soient pas une fine et
puisqu'on va pas se raconter d'histoires
on va pas se payer de mots on sait très
bien que ça va finir par un 49,3 on ne
sait pas quand exactement probablement
la semaine prochaine mais le
gouvernement peut dans le cadre du 49-3
ignorer totalement les votes de
l'assemblée c'est un droit qui est le
sien il peut aussi ajouter des amendes
qui ont été votés ou qui ne seront pas
votés parce que nous n'auront pas le
temps de le faire dans le cas d'un
travail de concertation avec les
oppositions mais également interne à la
majorité s'il ne garde rien c'est un peu
un coup de force c'est un peu presque
anti-démocratique n'a jamais été
question dans toutes les discussions que
nous avons eu que le gouvernement balaye
d'un revers de mal les amendements des
oppositions puis d'ailleurs vous avez
bien vu on met le focus sur ce qui va
mal et ce qui est
clivant mais il y a eu des votes depuis
mardi qui ont été faits de manière
consensuelle sur un certain nombre de
sujets où l'ensemble de l'hémicycle a
voté il y a même eu des votes à
l'unanimité sur certains amendements
notamment sur les
de ministère des armées hier il y a eu
un vote qui s'est fait l'unanimité il y
a eu un consensus et d'ailleurs au
départ le gouvernement donné un avis
défavorable avec Aurore berger nous
avons dit peut-être que là il faut
donner à l'opposition un gage de notre
bonne volonté et nous l'avons fait alors
il y a aussi un vote sur le retour de
l'excite taxe porté par les République 1
voté par les oppositions donc les sites
c'est cette taxe des chefs d'entreprise
qui vendent leur patrimoine en France
pour transférer leur domiciliation
fiscale à l'étranger vous comprenez le
rétablissement de cette taxe et vous
souhaitez aussi qu'elle soit conserver
au final dans le budget
je crois que le gouvernement va devoir
une fois qu'il aura décidé d'entamer la
procédure de 49-3 re balayer l'ensemble
des textes des amendements qui ont été
votés
tout ce que nous faisons nous le faisons
pour les Français et nous devons
répondre à leurs attentes à leurs
aspirations on doit le faire sans
démagogie moi je considère qu'il y a
certaines propositions qui sont
démagogiques notamment celle-ci il y en
a qui sont même contradictoires parfois
avec ce qu'on dit lorsqu'on est
candidats sa disposition sur l'exit tax
il faut faire la part des choses est-ce
qu'on veut devenir un pays attractif et
demeurer l'un des pays de la zone euro
les plus attractifs et ça passe par un
certain nombre de process notamment au
niveau fiscal qui rendent le pays
attractif ou est-ce qu'on veut aussi
dans un certain sens dans le même temps
être dans un justice et une justesse
parce que les Français aujourd'hui je le
pense ne comprennent pas un certain
nombre de choses et n'accepte plus à cet
homme de choses mais je crois que
certains de présentations d'amendement
parfois se font de manière
particulièrement démagogique et que on
sait que l'assemblée telle qu'elle est
composée peut parfois faire des votes un
peu surprenantes par celles et ceux qui
se joignent les uns aux autres pour
pouvoir les produire c'est un peu je
dirais une manière de faire de la
politique qui n'est pas la mienne si je
peux me permettre l'expression donc
rapidement pour conclure est-ce que le
groupe Horizon est pour le maintien de
cette excite taxe dans le texte au final
moi je pense que maintenant que
l'assemblée la beauté a une large
majorité le groupe horizon ne verrait
pas ne verrait pas un scandale d'autant
plus ça vient pas alourdir la charge
publique donc ça aussi peut-être une
mesure de justice juste pour terminer
pardon les crédits d'impôts pour les
résidents des panne notamment sur leur
reste à charge une mesure qui a été
votée par les oppositions cette mesure
aussi il faut la conserver là on est sur
une dépense en revanche et je vous
rappelle tout de même que
nous avons nous avons là nous avons à
charge également d'avoir une forme de
sérieux budgétaire dans l'édition que
nous prenons en tout cas c'est ce que LR
prétendait pendant sa campagne
électorale on nous accusé de cramer la
caisse donc vaut mieux peut-être joindre
la parole aux actes alors on va avancer
dans cette émission en attendant un
éventuel recours aux 49 ans on va parler
de la réforme des retraites qui arrivera
peut-être bientôt devant le Parlement le
gouvernement en attendant consulte et
Elisabeth borne a reçu les présidents de
groupe au Sénat et à l'Assemblée
nationale je vous écoutez la réaction
d'Olivier Marleix et André Chassagne
alors sorti de Matignon réaction
recueillies par Pierre et Soraya là où
ici
la première ministre nous a reçu pour
nous faire part de l'arrivée en janvier
de la réforme des retraites que ça
serait précédé d'une large consultation
qu'elle était ouverte aux amendements
qu'on pouvait proposer avec Eliana Sassi
nous avons dit qu'en ce qui nous
concerne bien évidemment on était
frontalement opposés à cette réforme que
cette réforme allait surtout pénalisée
les ceux qui sont le plus marqués par
leur par leur travail nous on est on est
ouvert une réforme de retraite parce
qu'on considère une fois encore que il y
a pas de miracle il y a pas de péril
immédiat sur notre système de retraite
mais si on veut revaloriser les pensions
il faut faire il faut faire une réforme
la question de l'âge de départ c'est
évidemment un paramètre ça des
paramètres les plus les plus efficaces
pour pour faire rentrer des recettes de
manière immédiate y avoir plus d'argent
à redistribuer mais encore faut-il
justement dire ce qu'on veut
redistribuer quelles peuvent être les
positive Laurent Marc Angeli vous avez
vous aussi en tant que président de
groupe président du groupe horizon à
l'Assemblée nationale vous avez été reçu
par Elisabeth borne comment ça s'est
passé que vous a-t-elle dit est-ce que
vous avez mis certaines lignes rouges
cette réforme des lignes rouges quand on
est avec ses amis on essaye avant tout
de faire valoir ce que nous pensons à ce
que nous croyons bon moi ce que je crois
bon d'abord c'est de poser le débat en
ces termes nous nous voulons sauver le
système par et partition à la française
c'est la première des batailles que nous
menons puis 1945 on a un système de
solidarité ce qui travaille paye pour
les retraités mais qui est très menacé
il est menacé et il est menacé de
manière imminente contrairement à ce que
disait mon collègue le président Marleix
vous n'êtes pas du tout d'accord avec
lui il est pas d'accord il y a une
urgence il y a une urgence même le corps
le dit maintenant nous avons des
déficits d'orientation des retraites le
Conseil d'orientation des retraites l'a
bien la bien précisé il y a des menaces
qui sont imminentes parfois parce que
nous avons aujourd'hui un déséquilibre
par rapport au fait que ce qui a cotise
sont de moins en moins nombreux par
rapport à ceux qui sont pensionnés qui
sont retraités et c'est l'équilibre même
du système qui est en péril il y a aussi
un problème de justice si je peux me
permettre dans notre système de retraite
aujourd'hui les Français je vous parle
tout à l'heure d'injustice qui n'accepte
plus ne comprennent plus que certains
légumes c'est donc de reculer l'âge de
départ quel âge il n'y a pas que ça
c'est ce n'est pas que ça cette réforme
c'est aussi ça aussi ça mais nous avons
la nécessité d'avoir un minimum déjà
1100 euros c'est ce que proposera je
l'espère le gouvernement parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez des gens qui
touchent des retraites qui sont
ils ont le inacceptables par rapport au
fait qu'ils aient travaillé toute leur
vie vous avez le fait d'en finir avec
certains régimes spéciaux nous
proposerons je l'espère que nous ayons
trois régimes un régime pour les
indépendants un vrai problème depuis des
années un régime pour les salariés et un
régime pour la fonction publique ensuite
je le dis l'âge doit également être au
centre du sujet pour une bonne et simple
raison c'est que aujourd'hui quand on
fait de la comparaison avec ce qui se
passe autour de nous les pays qui sont
autour de la France ont fait des choix
sur l'âge aussi et justement sur cette
question de l'âge de départ à la
retraite le patron de votre partie
Édouard Philippe l'ancien Premier
ministre a mis un peu la pression ce
week-end sur le gouvernement dans une
interview aux Parisiens justement en
comparaison la compa en comparant la
situation française aux autres pays
européens ils le dis l'Allemagne et
l'Italie ont choisi 67 ans je ne sais
pas par quel miracle de l'esprit on
pourrait être dans une situation
radicalement différente de celle de nos
voisins est-ce que les députés horizons
vont mettre sur la table dans le
prochain débat sur les retraites un
report de l'âge à 67 ans non nous ne
ferons pas en revanche Édouard Philippe
et fidèle à ce qu'il a toujours dit il a
dit il y a un an déjà dans le magazine
challenge la même chose il explique les
choses telles qu'elles existent à savoir
le fait que vous avez aujourd'hui des
pays qui sont voisins de la France et
qui ont fait le choix de 67 ans je
voudrais quand même qu'on s'attache à
faire un petit retour en arrière en 2010
le président Sarkozy a lancé une réforme
des retraites au départ c'était un
départ 64 ans qui était envisagé
finalement au gré des discussions ça
m'arrivait à l'âge de 62 ans
tout le monde savait tous les
spécialistes tous les commentateurs tous
les politiques savaient qu'à un moment
donné l'âge allait revenir sur la table
nous y sommes je rappellerai également
mais il faut bien définir un âge je
rappelle également que il y a deux ans
de cela Édouard Philippe en tant que
ministre a porté une réforme qui a été
votée en première lecture avec
l'utilisation du 49-3 à l'Assemblée
nationale et la question de l'âge était
aussi au centre du jeu donc moi ce que
je crois c'est qu'il faut pas qu'on
fasse preuve de démagogie sur la
question encore une fois on va essayer
d'être particulièrement sérieux dans
cette affaire parce que nous avons cette
réforme qui est très importante qui est
une réforme particulièrement
structurante et structurelle donc il
faut prendre le temps de la négociation
consulter consulter et jusqu'à quand pas
trop pas trop nous avons fixé un cap le
président de la République a fixé un cap
c'est celui d'une loi qui serait
effectivement allaité prochain qui
serait voté avant la fin de l'hiver par
le Parlement et je souscris pleinement à
ce calendrier en ce qui me concerne
justement vous avez été reçu hier par le
Président de la République et avec et
bien les membres de la majorité et la
Commission et des commissions et la
commission des affaires sociales de
l'Assemblée pour parler du budget de la
Sécurité sociale est-ce que il a été
évoqué la question de la réforme des
retraites et son calendrier bien sûr que
nous avons parlé de cette réforme le
calendrier de toute manière ça a été
arrêté il y a plusieurs semaines la
première ministre à la demande du
Président de la République a annoncé ce
calendrier c'est-à-dire avant la fin de
l'hiver une loi je souscris et je
soutiens cette démarche hier nous avons
parlé de cette réforme moi j'ai ce que
j'ai voulu rappeler hier en France du
président de la République et c'est ce
que je rappellerai pendant tous ces
débats c'est que dans ce
combat c'est un combat pour sauver notre
système de retraite par répartition il y
a deux piliers qu'on doit jamais oublier
le premier c'est le travail c'est pour
que le travail paye dans ce pays c'est
pour que la valeur travail soit
valorisée et le deuxième c'est la
justice aujourd'hui nous avons un
système de retraite qui comporte des
injustices il faut le réparer et il faut
le rendre plus juste une dernière petite
question très rapide sur un autre sujet
explosif puisque les consultations hier
vous avez eu ont aussi apparemment porté
sur les grèves dans les raffineries et
la colère par la colère qui monte la
droite estime que le gouvernement a très
mal géré cette crise vous que dites-vous
moi ce que je pense c'est qu'on ne
clôture jamais un conflit social par des
réquisitions et c'est ce rappeler la
première ministre il y a la nécessité de
réquisitionner le gouvernement doit
faire preuve d'autorité mais il doit le
faire à juste proportion ensuite les
salariés grévistes et les entreprises
doivent également amener leur part elles
doivent négocier et elles doivent sortir
de ce conflit et ensuite le gouvernement
pour protéger les Français parce
qu'aujourd'hui qui est pris en otage
dans cette histoire si ce n'est les
millions de Français qui n'arrivent pas
à aller travailler qui n'arrivent pas
amener leurs enfants à l'école donc je
pense que la prise en otage doit cesser
le gouvernement doit agir en fermeté
mais en respectant dialogue social et
les entreprises concernées leurs
salariés doivent un moment sortir de
crise par la boîte de négociation on va
maintenant parler de nos policiers
puisque le Sénat examiné cette semaine
le projet loi Love Me d'orientation et
de programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur contexte qui augmente les
moyens des forces de l'ordre sur le
quinquennat à venir à la majorité de
droite du sénati est favorable mais à
voter quelques modifications au texte
Jérôme Rabier
pour cette première loi d'orientation et
de programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin n'est pas
venu les mains vides au Sénat aux élus
issus des collectivités le ministre de
l'Intérieur a tenu un discours plein de
promesses les 200 brigades de
gendarmerie que nous allons recréer dans
l'ensemble de vos territoires lorsque le
gouvernement successif en a supprimé
plus de 500 depuis 30 ans dans
l'augmentation des effectifs de police
que nous continuons à faire dans
l'ensemble des commissariats et puis
pour la première fois depuis 17 ans
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs la
recréation de sous-préfecture et la
recréation d'agents de préfecture dans
les préfectures le ministre de
l'Intérieur arrivait aussi avec une
promesse financière de 15 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires pour les 5
prochaines années ainsi que la création
de 8500 postes et la transformation
numérique du ministère notamment un
package global qui a su séduire au delà
des rangs de la droite et du centre les
socialistes ont par exemple soutenu la
quasi-totalité des mesures on connaît la
situation du pays on connaît
l'aspiration à la sécurité exprimée par
les Français
il faut aller dans ce sens et nous
soutenons évidemment très clairement ce
point donc il est normal que ça ne fasse
pas finalement davantage débats le Sénat
a tout de même tenu à mettre sa patte
sur ce texte en renforçant les peines
pour les refus d'obtempérer les rodéo
urbains et pour les agressions contre
les élus des mesures qui ont été votées
à la quasi unanimité à l'exception des
sénateurs écologistes le rapporterait
l'air du texte saluer l'écoute
bienveillant du ministre mais appelle
désormais à aller encore plus loin le
reproche qu'on peut faire c'est qu'il y
a pas de
stéréophonie entre un texte police très
dynamique très innovateur et de l'autre
côté un texte justice qu'on attend comme
serein et on voit rien venir pour le
texte justice les parlementaires devront
encore patienter en revanche côté police
ils sont appelés à voter solennellement
cette loi de programmation et
d'orientation mardi en séance
le remarquantelli est-ce qu'a priori
vous êtes favorable à ce qu'a voter la
majorité de droite du Sénat sur ce texte
à savoir une augmentation de la peine de
prison pour refus d'obtempérer face aux
forces de l'ordre c'est un vrai sujet et
nous avons vu des drames encore
récemment encore récemment sur cette
question
il faut protéger nos policiers et je
vois que c'est un système de
co-construction qui s'est produit au
Sénat en réalité ministre ne sait pas
opposé à un certain nombre de
propositions qui ont été faites et je
trouve que c'est ça ce fonctionnement
donc nous allons
recevoir le moment venu cette loi à
l'Assemblée nationale moi ce que je vais
vous dire aujourd'hui avec certaines
formes de solennité nous allons aider le
ministre de l'Intérieur dans le cadre de
cette réforme qui est une réforme
importante tout à l'heure sur le projet
de loi de finance pourrait rappeler
également que des grandes mesures
régaliennes sont dans ce projet de loi
de finance des moyens supplémentaires
des recrutements pour avoir davantage de
force de l'ordre sur le terrain et la
loi locmi puisqu'elle s'appelle ainsi et
bien elle va venir je le pense renforcer
cette volonté de protéger les Français
il y a beaucoup de dispositions dans
cette dans ce projet de loi certains
parlent même d'un texte pour tout
notamment la question des violences
faites aux élus qui elle aussi fait
toujours l'actualité est-ce que vous
réclamez des peines exemplaires pour les
auteurs de violence contre les élus donc
moi je fais partie de ceux qui
considèrent que toute violence doit être
sévèrement puni ensuite il y a des
violences qui a sont remplies de
circonstances aggravées lorsqu'on s'en
prend à un fonctionnaire qui exerce sa
mission
fonctionnaire de police un magistrat ou
une magistrate mais également à un élu
c'est une circonstance aggravante un élu
il met son temps au service de ses
concitoyens c'est un serviteur et
lorsqu'on s'en prend à lui on s'en prend
une certaine idée de la République et de
la démocratie donc c'est une
circonstance Instagram peut-être ferme
et il faut que le crime ne paie pas
alors dans ce débat au Sénat c'est
invité dans la discussion une autre
polémique notamment sur la réforme de la
police judiciaire qui est menée
actuellement par le ministre de
l'Intérieur pour préciser cette réforme
l'idée c'est de rassembler au niveau
départemental tous les services de
police sécurité publique police aux
frontières et police judiciaire et de
les placer sous l'autorité d'un
directeur départemental de la police en
lien avec le préfet cette réforme
linquiète beaucoup la police judiciaire
les enquêteurs sur le terrain notamment
en Corse dans sur votre île le
remarquant jelly car les enquêteurs
corses estiment que cela va affaiblir la
lutte contre le grand banditisme est-ce
que vous êtes pour cette réorganisation
est-ce que vous comprenez l'inquiétude
des policiers on va voir la
réorganisation il y a une part qui est
purement réglementaire et qui sera à
charge pour le ministère de négocier
avec les organisations syndicales il y
aura également des élections
professionnelles le 8 décembre dans la
police et donc faire en sorte que cette
réforme se passe au mieux moi ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que j'ai Alda mana
du courage
parce que il est le premier ministre de
l'Intérieur depuis des années qui met
enfin en application des préconisations
qu'on entend depuis une trentaine
d'années par rapport à l'organisation de
la police dans notre pays et ce courage
il faut qu'il soit soutenu donc il sera
soutenu par les députés horizons et pas
le président du groupe horizon que je
suis et sur le territoire dont j'ai
l'honneur d'être l'élu qui est l'accord
moi je suis prêt à recevoir
personnellement les représentants
d'organisations syndicales pour leur
expliquer que le ministre de l'Intérieur
et bien mobilisé je peux vous le dire
pour la lutte contre le grand banditisme
parce que c'est l'un de ces objectifs
principaux concernant la Corse alors il
y a du travail à faire un travail
d'explication puisque cette réforme
suscite la colère parmi un nombre
important de policiers j'ai pu le
constater compris hors syndicat donc une
colère qui semble monter j'ai pu le
constater mais on parle d'une réforme
qui est je le pensais nécessaire il n'y
a pas que les moyens financiers les
moyens matériels les moyens humains il y
a aussi des moyens d'organisation
aujourd'hui ce que nous avons pu
constater c'est que la police nationale
la police judiciaire devait être
réorganisée cela fait plusieurs années
le courage doit payer Gérald Dahmane a
le ministre qui a mis cette réforme sur
le métier et il sera soutenu à en tout
cas par le groupe que je préside allez
on va finir cette émission en regardant
en regardant l'agenda de la semaine
prochaine au Parlement
et on va d'abord l'agenda de la semaine
à l'Assemblée nationale c'est la suite
du projet de loi de finance avec un
suspense lundi 18 octobre le
gouvernement 17 octobre même le
gouvernement pourrait choisir d'utiliser
l'article 49-3 de la Constitution pour
faire passer le budget sans vote du
Parlement et je dis place au budget de
la Sécu pour 2023 et au Sénat la semaine
prochaine plusieurs propositions de loi
déposées par des sénateurs vont être
débattus dans l'hémicycle mardi un texte
pour orienter les médecins internes vers
les déserts médicaux l'autre texte de ce
mardi pour mieux encadrer le recours de
l'État au cabinet de conseils après la
commission d'enquête du Sénat et puis
mercredi prochain c'est l'inscription du
droit à l'avortement dans la
Constitution qui sera débattue au Sénat
avec une proposition de loi à
l'initiative des sénateurs écologistes
alors le remarquandelli on a choisi de
vous interroger sur ce sujet du droit à
l'avortement puisque les députés
Renaissance veulent eux aussi déposer
une proposition de loi pour inscrire ce
droit dans la Constitution le patron du
MoDem François Bayrou a dit que c'était
pas du tout une priorité est plutôt
plutôt opposée quelle est votre position
sur ce texte je crois que il est une
bonne chose d'inscrire ce droit dans la
Constitution et lorsque ce débat viendra
à l'Assemblée nationale je crois qu'une
grande majorité voir même l'unanimité
des députés horizons il sera favorable à
quoi ça sert de mettre ce droit qui est
quand même fondamental tout le monde est
d'accord dans notre Constitution il y a
un risque brevet à une fois qu'il est
dans la Constitution un droit encore
plus fondamental si je peux me permettre
donc c'est aussi le fait de sacraliser
une réforme qui était une réforme
courageuse menée à maintenant de
nombreuses années qui n'étaient pas une
évidence ce sera le mot de la fin merci
le remarquant merci merci à tous de nous
avoir suivis et à la semaine prochaine
pour suivre l'actualité du Parlement
[Musique]